the fairway is open
once again tee off in the latest
installment of the mario golf series
coming to nintendo switch study the wind
and terrain
take your time to think things through
then
swing
[Music]
enjoy golfing with familiar mushroom
kingdom characters
on courses filled with lush natural
scenery
use features on the greens like a shock
gauge to see how your shot will curve
due to slopes
and a scan that lets you examine a
course's terrain
[Music]
these features can help you ace your
shots
[Music]
in addition to button controls you can
also use motion controls
by holding a joy-con controller like a
golf club
gently swing the controller to have your
character swing in the game
letting you easily enjoy the sensation
of golfing
on top of all that there are several
modes with new elements
that truly bring the heat to mario golf
including this one
speed golf here it's always your turn
everyone tees off at the same time then
you'll race through the course to reach
your ball
give it another whack to get it closer
to the hole then keep going
outpace your opponents to come out on
top your golfing skills aren't the only
things at play
make use of dashes and special shots to
beat the competition
oh did we mention story mode
as a me character you'll start out as a
rookie and develop your golfing skills
while interacting with various mushroom
kingdom characters
level up with experience points earned
during matches
then allocate points to different stats
allowing you to develop your character
however you'd like you can also use your
me
in versus play put your golfing skills
to the test
when mario golf super rush swings onto
nintendo
switch june 25th pre-orders begin on
nintendo eshop
after this presentation